وعشان طنط تذاكر روسيا بتعاهدتها في اتفاق
الحبوب وموسكو تتحدث عن تعليق الانسحاب
وتركيا تحذر من خطر من حي
ران تستعرض بمحاكمه
تلوحوا بالخيار العسكريه ضدها
ورئيس الامريكي يدعو شركات النفط لوقف
التربح من الحرب ويتواعدها بالضرائب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه نبداوها بهذه النشره قالت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان طلب روسيا
بالتزامات اوكرانيه بشان ممر الحبوب يعد
ابتزا جماعيا مشيره الى ان انسحاب روسيا
من اتفاق الحبوب له تاثير ضار على سوق
الغذاء العالمي واضافت الخارجيه الامريكيه
انه لا بديل عن تصدير الحبوب من اوكرانيا
الا عبر البحر الاسود داعيه مسيئه لتنفيذي
كامل تعهدتها بموجب اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
وكان رئيس الروسي بعد اوكرانيا الى ضمان
سلامه السفن التي تمر عبر ممر تصدير
الحبوب متهم بانها تشكل تهديدا بعد هجوم
استهداف الاسطول الروسي في القرن وشدد
بوتين على ان روسيا لم تنسحب من الاتفاق
بل علاقه التزامها به وذكر رئيس روسي انها
هجمات للاثنين على البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه كانت في جزء منها ردا على
الهجوم على الاصول الروسي في سفر بول
من جانبه وفي حديث العربيه قال وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا ان
الطرق البريه لا يمكن ان تغمي عن الممرات
الامنه عبر البحر الاسود محضرا من مخاطر
انسحاب روسيا المنفرد من الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
البريه
لتلبيه احتياجات السوق العالميه من الحبوب
الاوكرانيه لكنه لا يمكن ان تكون بديلا عن
الطرق البحريه واذا استمرت روسيا في
ابتزاز مبادره الحبوب فان اسعار الغذاء في
العالم سترتفع وسواجه الملايين المجاعه في
الطريقه الوحيده لضمان صادرات الحبوب
الاوكرانيه حول العالم بشكل سلس هي من
خلال الممرات الامنه في البحر الاسود
اما تركيا فحضرت من ان سفن الحبوب التي
تنتظر تفتيش في مضيق البوسفور اقرا تعليق
روسيا مشاركتها في تتفاق تصدير الحبوب من
اوكرانيا تشكل خطرا ملاحيا
موسكو
تظهر في الافق اسئله عده من بينها امكانيه
احياء اتفاق اسطنبول مجددا لكن هناك مشكله
اخرى تنتظر الحل هنا في بحر مرمره ما زالت
150 سفينه تنتظر الاذن بعبور مضيق بوسفور
هذه السفن كان ضمن اتفاق اسطنبول الخاص
بتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه وهي تنتظر قبال
اسطنبول منذ عده ايام من هذا الممر
البحريه عبرت عشرات السفن التي حملت اكثر
من تسعه ملايين طن من الحبوب كانت السفن
تعبر المضيق بعد تفتيشها من قبل مركز
التنسيق المشترك في اسطنبول الذي اشرف على
تنفيذ الارتفاع اليوم ومع انسحاب موسكو من
الاتفاق تعود قضيه السفن المنتظره قبال في
اسطنبول الى الواجهه فحتى اللحظه لا توجد
تصريحات الرسميه تؤكد او تنفي امكانيه [__]
لهذه السفن لخط سيرها الذي كان محددا قبل
انسحاب موسكو ويبدو ان مصيرها سيبقى معلقا
بمصير اتفاق اسطنبول نفسه زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للتقدريه رافاييل روسي ان الوكاله بدات
عمليات تفتيش لموقعين نوويين في اوكرانيا
بناء على طلبه بعد التهامات الروسيه بانها
تعمل على صنع ما يسمى بالقنبله القذره
قالت الوكاله في بيان ان مفتش الوكاله
بداوا وسينتهون قريبا من انشطه التحقق في
موقعين في اوكرانيا ومن المتوقع ان يقدم
دروسي في وقت لاحقا هذا الاسبوع
استنتاجاته الاوليه حول عمليه تفتيش
الى ايران حيث تواصلوا سلطات ومحاولتها
الحديثه لاخماد الاحتجاجات المتواصله في
مختلف انحاء البلاد مستخدمه كل الطرق
الممكنه لرضع المحتاجين اخر هذه الطرق
كانت اللجوء الى المحاكمات العالميه
والاحكام القاسيه ضد المحتاجين
النظام الايراني
هذا الاسبوع
بالاعدام في اول جلسه هل هذه عداله
اسلاميه في اي محكمه يصدرون حكما بالاعدام
في الجلسه الاولى انهم يريدون تنفيذ الحكم
باسرع ما يمكن رجاء ساعدونا
المحتجون رفعوا شعارات مطالبه بمحاكمه
رموز الفساد ليتم عكس ذلك عبر محاكمه
المحتجين من اجل كسر شوكه الاحتجاجات ولجم
السنه المتظاهرين اسلوب المحاكمه في حق
المطالبين بالحريه والعداله ورحيل النظام
ليست جديده في ايران اذتلك الطهران طريق
نفسه خلال احتجاجات 2009
و2019 ايضا وفي الوقت الذي تعرف فيه
البلاد غليان الشعبيا وارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا في صفوف المتظاهرين الى اكثر من
200 قتيلا بينهم اطفال برصاص الامن وفقا
منظمات حقوقيه ايرانيه صحف تابعه للحكومه
الايرانيه دافعت عن انشطه قوات الامن
وقالت انه لم يقتل اي محتج حتى الان مشيره
الى ان القتل جميعهم من قوه الامن عكس ما
تقوله الصور الوارده بلال الوجداني
العربيه
[تصفيق]
وعلى خلفيه قمع الاحتجاجات والمحاكمات
فرضت وزاره الخارجيه الكنديه حزن تعقبات
جديده على النظام الايراني ردا على ما
وصفته بالانتهاكات الجسيمه لحقوق الانسان
العقوبات الكنديه على زهران جميله
ايرانيين معظمهم شاركوا بصوره مباشره في
اضطهاد الجائر ومنهج لاحدى الاقليات
الدينيه حسب بيان وزاره الخارجيه الكنديه
من جانبه يحمل المبعوث الامريكيه الخاصه
لشؤون ايران روبرت مالي النظام مسؤوليه
قتل المتظاهرين المبعوث الامريكي قال ان
امريكان ستدرس استخدام القوه العسكريه ضد
ايران اذا فشلت المحادثات لاعاده يحيى
الاتفاق النووي اضافه مالي خلال حديثه في
ندوه عبر الانترنت لمؤسسه واشنطن كاندي
انطلاكه ايران سلاح نويا سيجعل العالم اقل
امنا وبعد تصريحات مالي فرضت الخارجيه
الايرانيه عقوبه او الخارجيه الامريكيه
عقوبات على 10 اشخاص واربعه كيانات
امريكيه لتحرضهم على العنف في ايران حسب
الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
الامريكيين وزياده الانتاج او دفع المعدل
ضرائب الاعلى
اعتقد ان عليهم مسؤوليات التصرف لصالح
المستهلكين ومجتمعهم وبلدهم للاستثمار في
امريكا من خلال زياده الطاقه الانتاجيه
والتكرير لا يريدون فعل ذلك لديهم الفرصه
للقيام بذلك تخفيض الاسعار للمستهلكين في
المضخه كما تعلم اذا لم يفعلوا ذلك فسوف
يدفعون ضريبه اعلى على ارباحهم الزائده
وسيواجهون قيودا اخرى سيعمل فريق مع
الكونجرس للنظر في هذه الخيارات المتاحه
لنا وللاخرين
حفله الاتحاد الاوكراني لكره القدم الفيفا
على استبعاد منتخب ايران من كاس العالم
المقرر اجرؤها الشهر الجاري بقطر بدعوه
انتهاك زهران لحقوق الانسان وتزويد الجيش
الروسي بالاسلحه وجاء طلب الاوكرانيه قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع من موعد مواجهه ايران مع
انجلترا في اول مباراه بالمجموعه الثانيه
في كاس العالم ولم يطلب لتحاضر اوكراني
استبدال منتخب ايران في البطوله بالمنتخب
الاوكراني الذي لم يتمكن من بلوغ نهائيات
واسطه اجراء عمليه مشدده يتوجه الناخبون
في اسرائيل اليوم الى مراكز الاقتراع
للمره الخامسه في اخر اربع سنوات
العوده للسلطه
اسرائيل طوقا امنيا شاملا على الضفه
الغربيه
المزيد من التفاصيل في التقرير الثاني
مشاهد من مدينه الخليل العشيه الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه جرافات اسرائيليه تنهش بيت
مواطن فلسطيني في منطقه البقعه بذريعه عدم
الترخيص
سبق ذلك توغل لقوات خاصه في جنين ونابلس
واشتباكات مع مقاومهم
يخالف كل القوانين الدوليه من خلال منع
العمل منع السفر منع التنقل واليوم في
مدينه الخليل او في مدينه نابلس يضع
الحوادث
المواطنين من ال- ال- ال- الخروج بشكل
وهذا شكل من اشكال العقاب الجماعي
اغلاق ومداخل المدن بالسواتر الترابيه
ونصب حواجزه وتفتيشات مشدده على حركه
المواطنين سياسه لم تمارسها اسرائيل منذ
نحو 20 عاما كلها عادت الى الواجهه ورغم
كل ذلك فان عمليات اطلاق النار والدهس
التي ينفذها الفلسطينيون اخذه بالازدياد
مع دعوات صريحه من مجموعات مسلحه لمهاجمه
اهداف اسرائيليه خلال الانتخابات
تقوم به الجهات الامنيه الاسرائيليه في
الاعياد والمناسبات للحد من امكانيه
التسلل الفلسطينيين وتنفيذ عمليات في
الداخل لكن هذه المره يبدل الامر مختلفا
مع وتيره العنف المتصاعده
يعتبر هذا العام الاكثر دمويه منذ سبعه
اعوام من ناحيه عدد القتلى بين الجانبين
البعض يعزل الامر لعدم استقرار سياسي
تعاني منه اسرائيل والتي تخوض انتخابات
خامسه في غضون ثلاثه اعوام تنتج حكومات
غير قادره على التقدم في المسار التفاوض
مع الجانب الفلسطيني
عبد الحفيظ جوعان العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
رغم اصدارها بيانا بضغط من المعارضه يوضح
تفاصيل حادثه استخدام بريدها الشخصيه
لارسال الملفات الحكوميه ردت وزيره
الداخليه البريطانيه سورلا بريبرمان مساء
الاثنين على اتهامات النواب بشان خلقها
القواعد الوزاريه من جهه وبشان الاجراءات
التي ستتخذها لايجاد حل لازمه اقتراضي احد
مراكز الاحتجاج المهاجرين في جنوب شرق
انجلترا من جهه الثانيه
وزيره الداخليه تخرج عن صمتها بعد اسبوع
من عودتها الى الحكومه
اعترافها باستخدام باريدها الشخصيه لارسال
وثائق حكوميه بينها ست مرات الى بريدي
الالكتروني الخاص وذلك ردا على استفسارات
النواب بشان خلقها قواعد وزاريه ما ارغمها
سابقا على الاستقاله من حكومه الاسترس
براما اكدت ان المستندات لا تشكل تهديدا
للامن الوطني فيما تواصل المعارضه
التشكيكها في نزاهه رئيس الوزراء سوناك
لاعادتها الى منصبها السابق بعد سته ايام
فقط من استقالتها وتجدد مطالبتها بفتح
تحقيق في الانتهاكات الامنيه
هل يمكن ان تخبرنا ما اذا كانت في الواقع
قد خرقت القانون الوزاري الذي ينص على
التزام الوزراء بالقانون
الوزاريه ثلاثه مرات في يوم واحد وكيف
يفترض ان يثق بها اي شخص كوزيره داخليه مع
هذه القضايا الخطيره
[تصفيق]
الى اللجنه البرلمانيه المكلفه بشؤون
الداخليه التي ارسلتها اليوم لقد اوضحت
انني ارتكبت خطا واعتذرت عن هذا الخطا
وتحملت المسؤوليه عنه
في هذه المساله الطارئه ايضا انتقد
المحافظون والمعارضه على السواء احتجاجا
ما يصل الى 4000 مهاجر في ظروف بائسه في
مركز مقتض بجنوب شرق انجلترا واطلعت ابرا
من النواب انها تبحث في جميع الخيارات
المتاحه لايجاد سكن بديل للمهاجرين على
عكس اتهامها برفض نقل المهاجرين الى
الفنادق واذا اكد التصميمها على وقف تهريب
المهاجرين رفضت الاتهامات بتراكم ملفات
طالب اللجوء مشدده على انها تنظر في جميع
طلبات التي يتجاوز عددها 100.000 طلب
وزيره الداخليه
تحت المجهري مجددا اعتذارها المتواصل عن
ارسال ملفات حكوميه عبر بريدها الخاص لم
يقنع المعارضه وبعدا وبحبها وفي حال لم
تنجح في ايجاد حل سريع لازمه مركز احتجاز
اللاجئين في مقاطعه كانت لا يبدو ان
الهجوم عليها سيت فوفو في الماده المنظور
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز تقدم المرشح
الديمقراطيه العضويه مجلس الشيوخ عن
بنسلفانيا
5 نقاط مئويه عن المرشح الجمهوري محمد اوس
وحسب استطلاع نيوت تايم زفاف 49% من
الناخبين يؤيدون فطرمان فيما يؤيد اوز نحو
44% ويدعم رئيس الامريكي جو بيضا
الديمقراطيه فطرمان في حملته فيما يدعم
الرئيس السابق ترامب الجمهوري محمد اوس
حيث تعدد بن سيلفينيا من الولايات الحاسمه
لكل الحزبين في سعيهما لسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ وياتي لاستطلاعه رغم المناظره
الاخيره بين الرجلين والتي اوضحت معاناه
سترمان خلال الحديث لاصابته بجلطه دماغيه
قبل خمسه اشهر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يوسين صنعت سبورت
انا حسين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الانتخابات الحاليه
تتحدث الى اصحاب الاعمال الصغيره عن تاثير
التضخم على سير اعمالهم والمفاجاه انهم
يعانون اكثر من نظره اليد العامله
التفاصيل مع الزميل
يعتبر الامريكيون ان الاقتصاد في مقدمته
اهتماماتهم بنسبه 77% وكل ما اشترى الناخب
وقودا او سلعا من المحلات يشعر ان الاسعار
ارتفع واستغل الجمهوريون الامر ووضعه في
صلب حملتهم الانتخابيه خلال هذه الجوله
الميجانيه في مدرب تنسافينيا سالنا اصحاب
المطاعم والمحلات التجاريه عن سير الاعمال
وسماعنا كلاما مختلفا صاحب هذا المطعم في
حارسبر يقول ان العمل جيد
جدا كان افضل قبل الجائحه ولكننا نعود الى
الحركه التي كانت من قبل
المثير للملاحظه ان صاحب مقهى اخر في
درسبرج بن سيلفينيا اشار الى الامر الذاتي
والرايان يتناقضان مع حمله الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات الحاليه
خفضنا ساعه العمل كثيرا ولدينا عمال اقل
ولكن على الرغم من خفض ساعات التشغيل الا
ان الدخله جيد
المثير اكثر في هذه المساله ان اصحاب
المقاهي والمطاعم يعانون من ندره اليد
العامله وطلب العمال
يمكن ان يكون افضل ولكن الامور ليست سيئه
وبين رساله الجمهوريين للناخبين باختيار
مرشحين يرفعون عنهم اعباء موجه الغلاء
ورساله الديمقراطيين بان الرئيس بيدن يقوم
بكل ما في وسعه لمواجهه مشكله لم يتسبب
بها يبدو اصحاب الاعمال غير اكيدين من
تصويبهم وربما يريدون الابتعاد قليلا عن
النقاش السياسيه
الغلاء مشكله ضربت الاقتصاد الامريكي منذ
اكثر من عام ويحاول الجمهوريون ان يقولوا
ان هذه المشكله تسبب بها الديمقراطيون
ولكن حتى الان اصحاب المحلات الصغيره لا
يعتبرون ان هذه المساله هي مشكله كبيره
بعد ما تم تاجيله تلك التحقيقات منذ اكثر
من عامين وبموجب الحكم سيتم تحقيقه في
جرائم من ارتكبها حركه طالبان وتنظيم داعش
بعد ما قال القضاء ان تحقيقات في كابول لا
تجرى بشكل قانونيا وعملي 2
اطلقت الصين الواحده الثالثه والاخيره
لاستقبال محطه الفضائيه دائمه ضمن مسعا
استمر اكثر من عقد كامل لايجاز المحطه
وضمان استمرار تواجد طاقمها في المدار
[موسيقى]
تعويضات متاخره بملايين الدولارات بعد
التبريقه من تهمه اغتيال النشط الحقوقي
مالكوم اكس المتهمين باغتيال الرجل وبعد
سنه من تبريئاتهما نجح في الحصول على
تعويض يقدر بس 36 مليون دولار مقابل ادانه
خاطئه هذا فضلا عن 10 ملايين دولار اضافيه
ستدفعها ولايه نيويورك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تمسك تحالف الحريه
والتغيير برؤيته حول السعاده الحكم المدني
الديمقراطي ونفى ان تكون هناك تسويه
ثنائيه مع المكون العسكريين فيما رفضت
مجموعه التوافق الوطنيه اي محاوله
لاستعاده الشرك القديمه وانها ستقوم
بهزيمتها وفي الاثناء قال رئيس الجبهه
الثوريه ان شركاء السلام على استعداد
لتقديم تنازل من اجل الحل
الطريق الى حل للازمه السياسيه في السودان
لا يبدو معبدا بخيارات يسيره على الفاعلين
في المشهد السياسي تحالف الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي اختتم مؤتمر سياسي معلنا
التمسك برؤيته وقطع بعدم وجود تسويه
ثنائيه وانما عمليه سياسيه تشمل جميع قوى
الثوره والانتقال يعني
ثنائي يعيد الحبوب العمليه السياسيه التي
تتمناها الحريه
والتغيير وتريدها هي اعلنت مرارا انها
تتطلب يعني قاعده واسعه بالقوه الثوره ومن
قوه الانتقال
وعلى ضفه الاخرى ترى مجموعه التوافق
الوطني ان العوده الى الشراكه الثنائيه
السابقه ستتهزم بحسب تغريده للامين العام
لمجموعه التوافق الوطني
السلام تتمسك باتفاقيه جوبا من جانب وتقول
انها مستعده للتنازل من جانب الاخر
للحوار الايجابي ان احنا نتعاطى معه وما
عندنا مشكله وممكن نقدم همم اي تنازل ناس
شايفين في مصلحه البلد
[موسيقى]
ومع الانقسامات السياسيه يبقى هنالك طرف
فاعل الذي يتمثل بالشارع المتظاهر ضد
التسويه الذي يبحث عن اهدافه بحكومه مدنيه
وقد اصدر جدولا تصعيديا لشهر نوفمبر يشمل
تظاهرات ومواكب عديده
الباحث لحل للازمه السياسيه في السودان
يدرك صعوبه المهمه فالكل هنا لا يريد
للسودان ان ينزلق الى المربع الاسود
سياسيا واقتصاديا وامنيا لقاءات الاليه
الثلاثيه والرباعيه حتى الان لم تستطع
الوصول الى نقطه الوفاق وان بشرت من قبل
ذلك محمد عثمان العربيه الخضر
قتل طفلان واجرح اربعه اخرون جراء سقوط
قطيفه هاون اطلقتهما الميليشيا الحوثيه
غرب مدينه تعز الحكومه اليمنيه طلبه
المجتمع الدوليه باتخذه موقف واضح من
جرائم القتل اليوميه التي ترتكبها مليشيا
الحوثي بحق سكان مدينه تعز
هذا ويشهد حي المطار القديم
غدر المنزل الى المدرسه مشيان على الاقدام
لكنهم عادوا اليه مبتوري الاطراف في
الطريق باغتهم مقذوف الحوثي فلم يفقوا منه
الا في طوارئ المشفى كل منهما بقدم واحد
هكذا اذا ارتكبت الميليشيات مجزره مروعه
بحق اطفال تعز في حي المطار القديمه غربي
المدينه
اخرى بمقذوف اخر وعلى الحي نفسه قتل
العائد للاسره هذه مع طفله ليوم الحزن
ارجاء المنزل وترتفع اعداد الضحايا بذلك
الى قتيلين وخمسه اتجاهها كلهم من الاطفال
واجي اشوف البيت كله مكسر وجهه ميت
واشوف اي اخره ابن عمي
وابن عمي
رجله
مبخوتيه بحق الاطفال في المنزل هذا غربي
اطفالنا يعني اقسم
مغلش يتحمل
تعيش عشيره الاسر اليمنيه في الحج هذا
بيرعب دائم فمن نجا هنا من قناصه
الميليشيات قد لا يلجو مطلقا من مقذوفتها
التي تستهدفهم يوميا في منازلهم سعيد
العربيه تعز
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تهمه الاعتداء على احد افراد عائله مسؤول
ومحاولته
والاقتحام الى الامريكي
زوج نانسي فلوسي بما طريقتين هددها باخذها
كرهينه وكسر ركبتها اذا كذبت عليه في
استجوا به لها وذكرت الدعوه ان المتسلله
ابل بول فلوسي بانه يعتدي محتجازه زوجته
رهينه للاستجواب وانه اذا قالت الحقيقه
فسوف يتركها تذهب رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي
فلوسي والتي كانت في واشنطن وقت الهجوم
قالت ان زوجها يتحسن تدريجيا لكنه سيحتاج
لعمليه تعف طويله ويرقد زوجها بول بلو سي
في المستشفى حيث يتعافى من قصور في
الجمجمه واصابه في يده وذراعه اليمنى
قلى الملياردير لهم ماسك الذي استحوذ على
شركه سويسرا مقابل 44 مليار دولار ان
التزام من وسط التواصل الاجتماعيه بسلامه
العلامه التجاريه لم يتغير وكان التقارير
اعلاميه افادت بان ماسك قام بحل مجلس
اداره موقع تويتر واعلن بانه سيكون رئيس
التنفيذي للشركه وقم ماسك في وقت سابقا
بتغيير وصفه في سيرته الذاتيه على المنصه
الى رئيس السويسري في اشاره الى هذه
الخطوه
صحيفه واشنطن بورصه الامريكيه او ردت نقلا
عن نظره عن شركه تويتر التي استحود عليها
الملياردير الى مصر الاسبوع الماضي
تعتزموا تسريحه ربع موظفيها في اطار ما
يتوقع ان تكون الجوله الاولى من الاستغناء
عن عاملين في الشركه وجاء في تقرير
الصحيفه ان المحامي المشهور اليكس برو وهو
ممثل قانوني لمصر منذ وقت طويل قدر
مناقشات الخاصه بتخفيضات الوظائف وحسب سجل
تنظيمي زاد عدد العاملين في تويتر في
نهايه عام 20 21 على سبعه الاف موظف
ويصلوا عدد العاملين في الشركه الى ما
يقارب ال 2000
وبعد ايام فقط من تواليه اداره احدى اكثر
من اصوات التواصل الاجتماعيه تاثيرا في
العالم قال الماسك ان تويتر سيعدل عمليه
التحقق من المستخدمين
تويتر
قبل الاستحواذ وبعده صاحب القرار في تويتر
اليوم يسعى لوضع بصمته الخاصه ورسم
الملامح الجديده على المنصه ذات التاثير
التواصلي الاجتماعيه الكبير عالميا
بعد ايام فقط من تواليه اداره تويتر بدائل
ماسك الحديثه عن التعديلات ونقلت مصادر
عنه انه سيعدل عمليه التحقق من المستخدمين
في حين قالت النشره الاخباريه التكنولوجيه
للمنصه ان تويتر يدرس فرض رسوم على علامه
التحقق الزرقاء المخصصه للتحقق من هويه
صاحب
الحسابين الاشتراك في علامه تويتر الزرقاء
بسعر اربعه دولارات و99 سنتا في الشهر او
فقد شعراتهم الموثقه في حاله تطبيق
المشروع
الاثاره على المنصه وعلى صفحه الماس
تحديدا لم تغب لحظه المالك الجديد لتويتر
تحدث عن انه سيشكل مجلسا للاشراف على
المحتوى و وعد المعلنين بان الموقع لم
يتحول الى منصه مجانيه للجميع واصفا نفسه
بانه مطلق حريه التعبير في الاثناء دخل
ماسك في اخذ ورد مع صحيفه نيويورك بعد ان
هاجم تقريرا للصحيفه نهج ماسك تجاه
المعلومات المضلله خصوصا بعد رده على هلال
كلينتون برابط موقع اخباري يشكك في روايه
الاعتداء على زوج رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي
في لوسي وحذفه للتغريده لاحقا وكتب ماسك
ساخرا من الصحيفه ومقتبسا عنوانها هذا
مزيف لم اغرد برابط لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
على تويتر في اشاره مواطنه الى ان الصحيفه
تنشر اخبارها مزيفه
ماسك وترامب اسمعني برعاه في استخدام
تويتر ترامب الرئيس الامريكي السابق ونجم
تويتر تجاوز الاعلام التقليدي في يوم ما
واضعا نهجا مختلفا لتصريحات الرئاسه
ومعتمدا حديث التغريد التساؤلات لم تتوقف
عن عوده حساب ترامب الى تويتر خاصه وان
مالكه الجديد تربطه علاقه جيده مع الرئيس
السابق التحليلات تقول ان عهده ترامب
الذهبي مع تويتر قد انقضى فالمتابعون
لترامب تشبعوا من تغريداته بسبب افراضه في
التغريد عدا ان ترامب نفسه لم يعد بحاجه
الان الى تويتر فهو يملك ويدير من قصته
الخاصه
في اعداد المشتركين الا ان ترامب لديه
مصلحه ماليه مباشره في نجاح الشركه كما ان
اكبر رصيد تملكه السوشيال هو دونالد ترامب
قالت انستغرام انها اصبحت خطا مبرمجيا منع
الاف المستخدمين من الوصول الى منصه
مشاركه الصور لنحو ثماني ساعات وادى الى
شكاوى من تعليق الحسابات واوضحت انستغرام
المملوكه لشركه ميت بليد في تغريده لها
على تويتر انها اصبحت الان الخطا الذي كان
يتسبب في مشكلات في وصول اشخاص من اجاز من
اجزاء مختلفه من العالم الى حساباتهم
وتسبب في تغيير المؤقت بالنسبه للبعض في
عدد المتابعين